[англійською] Мене часто запитували:
«То ти збираєшся написати книгу
[англійською] про традиційну українську кухню
з картоплею, капустою та варениками?»
[англійською] І мені доводилося відповідати,
[англійською] що Україна поділяється на регіони,
[англійською] так само, як Франція чи Італія.
[англійською] На півночі — ліси, а на півдні — степ,
[англійською] море і середземноморський клімат.
[англійською] Завдяки цьому, а також сезонності,
[англійською] страви української кухні дуже різноманітні.
[англійською] Це не лише картопля, капуста і вареники.
[англійською] Будяки треба прибрати,
вони тут не мають бути.
[англійською] У мене тут росте буряк,
польові квіти, все дике.
Тут не так багато сонця, не так, як на Україні.
Народилася я в Каховці, що на Херсонщині.
Батьки мої з Вознесенська, в Миколаївщині.
Мамина сім'я переважно з Бессарабії,
батько тата з Вінниці, а його мама з Сибіру.
Найважливіші, найяскравіші спогади з дитинства —
це природа, сім'я, їжа.
Коли ми були на природі біля Дніпра
чи з мамою ми щось сапали,
їли суницю, огірки, літом, коли перші були.
Для мене це найяскравіші спогади.
Коли я була маленька,
з двох років у мене була жахлива астма.
У 1998 році ми поїхали в Кіпр,
і там вперше я не задихалася,
почувалася дуже добре.
Тож з дванадцяти років я жила на Кіпрі 5 років.
Мені було дуже важко,
бо я не розмовляла англійською мовою,
але вступила в англійську школу.
І коли мені вже було 15 років,
тоді були державні екзамени в школі.
І я була одна з трьох в моєму класі,
з найвищою оцінкою з англійської мови.
І зараз, як ви бачите,
я ще перемикаюсь між мовами,
зараз мені важко розмовляти українською.
бо я думаю і навіть мрію англійською мовою.
[англійською] Я мала можливість
приїхати до Сполученого Королівства,
[англійською] подалась до багатьох університетів
[англійською] і врешті навчалась  в Університеті Ворика.
[англійською] Ступінь бакалавра я здобула
у графстві Західний Мідлендс, у Центральній Англії,
[англійською] а магістратуру вже закінчувала в Лондоні.
[англійською] Тут і залишилась.
[англійською] Я була одержима готуванням.
[англійською] Я обожнювала готувати.
[англійською] Двадцятирічною,
я почала багато готувати вдома.
[англійською] Я заробляю собі на життя
написанням кулінарних книжок.
[англійською] Це не завжди просто,
[англійською] адже видавнича індустрія Великобританії
[англійською] переживає складні часи.
[англійською] Тож не кожна книжка принесе гроші.
[англійською] Мені пощастило,
особливо з першою книгою, «Мамушка».
[англійською] Думаю, це перша
кулінарна книга сучасного формату
[англійською] про східноєвропейську кухню,
що вийшла в  Сполученому Королівстві.
[англійською] Тож, як на нішеву кухню, вона мала успіх.
[англійською] Вона продалась
накладом у 150 тисяч примірників
[англійською] по всьому світу,
була перекладена сімома мовами
[англійською] та стала дуже популярною в США.
Ми їдемо в Нижнє селище.
Скільки нас буде?
Десять людей з Великої Британії та Америки.
Це п'ята експедиція, ми вже робимо так п'ятий рік.
[англійською] Через рік після публікації «Мамушки»
[англійською] я розказала подрузі,
фотографині Елені Хезервік,
[англійською] яка тоді знімала для моєї другої книги,
«Кавказ», про літні кухні.
[англійською] Вона зацікавилася,
і ми вирішили поїхати до України та зробити фото.
[англійською] Ще я залучила свого чоловіка, Джо,
[англійською] теж фуд-фотографа,
тож ми троє, наче мандрівний цирк,
[англійською] об'їхали всю Україну.
[англійською] Здається,
ми їздили п’ять разів, і були всюди,
[англійською] крім Сходу — щоб не ризикувати.
[англійською] Ми також хотіли поїхати до Криму,
[англійською] поспілкуватися з татарами,
[англійською] але для цього
довелося б летіти через Москву.
[англійською] Я не схотіла цього робити,
[англійською] тож ми не поїхали в Крим і Східну Україну.
[англійською] Але ми охопили так багато, як могли,
[англійською] проїхавши близько десяти тисяч кілометрів.
[англійською] Ходили до людей
додому —  і на кухню.
[англійською] Ми відвідували друзів своїх друзів і людей,
[англійською] яких мені порадили через інстаграм.
[англійською] Вони мені писали щось типу:
[англійською] «О, я маю неймовірну бабусю в Полтаві,
[англійською] і вона має літню кухню».
[англійською] І тепер у нас є колекція цих рецептів.
[англійською] Найбільше мене
цікавили незвичайні рецепти,
[англійською] які не піддалися радянському впливу.
[англійською] Мені було важливо відкопати те,
[англійською] що було, по суті, уже поховано.
[англійською] Тож передусім
я просила старших жінок,
[англійською] з якими говорила на літніх кухнях,
[англійською] пригадати рецепти,
за якими готували їхні мами чи бабусі.
[англійською] Можливо, ви так уже
не готуєте, щось що ви пам'ятаєте.
[англійською] І це було досить складно,
бо вони казали:
[англійською] «Та що цікавого?
Та боже, літня кухня, та ні-ні!»
[англійською] Я прагнула створити
збірку регіональних рецептів —
[англійською] з певної місцевості,
певного регіону чи навіть сім'ї.
[англійською] І записати дивовижні історії,
[англійською] що можуть зникнути безвісти,
і ми їх уже ніколи не дізнаємося.
[англійською] Тому цей проєкт має історичний,
[англійською] а саме — антропологічний сенс.
[англійською] Моя улюблена частина —
похід у гори до вівчарів.
[англійською] Ми піднімаємось усі разом,
і це прекрасно.
[англійською] Ти йдеш полонинами,
і вони так пахнуть!
[англійською] Природа просто невимовно красива.
[англійською] Потім ми підходимо до вівчарів.
[англійською] Вони всі дуже цікаві люди.
[англійською] В останні наші візити
вони робили сир із сирого молока.
[англійською] І всі в моїй групі,
включно з моїм чоловіком,
[англійською] пробували щойно
видоєне молоко (є навіть відео).
[англійською] І всі були в грі: мовляв,
так, без проблем, ми спробуємо це.
[англійською] Не кожен у Сполученому Королівстві,
[англійською] скажу я вам,
пив би сире молоко, з міркувань безпеки.
[англійською] Але не в моїх гастрономічних турах.
[англійською] У моїх гастротурах всі пробують.
[англійською]  Так, це досить
проста страва з мого рідного регіону.
[англійською]  Вона зветься «тузлук».
[англійською] Тузлук.
[англійською] Можливо, це татарська страва,
[англійською] адже цим словом
називають ропу у тюркських мовах.
[англійською] Тузлук не готують удома —
тільки на природі.
[англійською] Для нього потрібна ягнятина, вода,
[англійською] а зараз ми робимо
до нього заправку, яка називається «льок».
[англійською]  Це дрібно порізана цибуля,
[англійською] яку я протушкую
в гарячому бульйоні з коріандром.
[англійською] Ми готуємо кілька страв
і влаштовуємо пікнік.
[англійською] Ви не дуже любите м'ясо?
[англійською] Так, не найбільша прихильниця.
[англійською] Тоді я вам покладу зовсім трошки.
[англійською] Дякую дуже, супер!
[англійською] Кому ще?
[англійською] Це одна з моїх улюблених частин.
[англійською] Я роблю багато майстер-класів.
[англійською] Ми ліпимо вареники і печемо паляниці.
[англійською] Це чудове свято,
де ми готуємо разом, спілкуємося
[англійською] та знайомимося
з чудовими місцевими мешканцями.
[англійською] З днем народження, Саймон.
[англійською] Будьмо!
[англійською] Це не лише про те,
щоб привезти людей
[англійською] з усього світу до України.
[англійською] Ми дуже багато вкладаємось
у спільноти і їхній розвиток.
[англійською] Після публікації
книжок я буваю на телебаченні.
[англійською] Разів п’ятнадцять після виходу «Мамушки»
[англійською] мене запрошували  на ранкове шоу на BBC,
[англійською] яке називається «Суботня кухня».
[англійською] 2–3 мільйони людей
щосуботи вмикають цю передачу...
[англійською] Декілька разів вони мене запрошували.
[англійською] Коли я просувала «Кавказ»,
то готувала грузинські страви,
[англійською] але здебільшого готую українську кухню.
[англійською] І, ви знаєте, люди теж готують.
[англійською] Просять позначити їх
в інстаграмі або зізнаються мені,
[англійською] що раніше уявлення
не мали про борщ, думали, що це  суп-пюре,
[англійською] а тепер варять його з коров'ячими хвостами
[англійською] або з чорносливом.
[англійською] І це неймовірно —
бачити британську публіку,
[англійською] яка відкриває
для себе новий смаковий профіль,
[англійською] подекуди дуже екзотичний для неї.
[англійською] От, наприклад, у Великій Британії
зараз в тренді ферментація.
[англійською] Коли ж я в Україні кажу «ферментація»,
моя сім'я сміється, мовляв,
це квашення, а не ферментація.
[англійською] Українська кухня — це про зв'язок.
[англійською] Я пояснюю це на початку книги.
[англійською] На обкладинці гарні жовті
черешні, що ростуть з літньої кухні.
[англійською] Так сталося, коли мій
дідусь Віктор, десь у ранніх 1960-х,
[англійською] коли моя мама була ще зовсім маленькою,
[англійською] в'їхав з родиною в новий будинок.
[англійською] Там не було літньої кухні,
[англійською] а він вважав її необхідною,
тож почав будувати.
[англійською] На подвір’ї росла жовта черешня,
[англійською] і одна з її гілок заважала будівництву.
[англійською] Але дідусь любив ту черешню,
[англійською] і не став її ані рубати, ані обрізати.
[англійською] Вона росла в будівлі та вийшла через дах.
[англійською] Чи це не фантастика?
Для мене — точно.
[англійською] Це просто любов і повага до землі
[англійською] та всього, що на ній росте.
Україна для мене про це.
[англійською] Це про мою родину,
моїх предків, спільну історію та травми,
[англійською] які ми ділимо з усіма українцями
[англійською] й які насправді
назавжди з нами залишаться.
[англійською] Я росла з усіма цими історіями.
[англійською] Вибачте, я занадто емоційною стаю.
[англійською] А також земля.
Тому дуже захоплююся людьми,
[англійською] що просувають
не лише рецепти, але й етнос, почуття,
[англійською] які мали наші бабусі
й дідусі та їхні предки.
[англійською] Радянський Союз
знищив так багато української культури,
[англійською] їжі, мови.
[англійською] Тому я відчуваю,
що це обов'язок мого покоління —
[англійською] зберегти та донести
усі ці старі рецепти та історії.
[англійською] Якщо ви це дивитесь
і ваша бабуся ще жива —
[англійською] підіть і розпитайте її.
[англійською] Запишіть відповіді,
зв'яжіться з Мар'яною Душар,
[англійською] яка робить прекрасний проєкт,
[англійською] у якому збирає ці рецепти з усієї України.
[англійською] Допоможіть їх зібрати
та зберегти, і, можливо,
[англійською] так ми зможемо
повернути якусь частину цих рецептів.
[англійською] Вибачте, що я не українською.
[англійською] Обіцяю читати українською,
[англійською] бо я маю кілька книжок
нагорі, і я далі практикуватиму.
[англійською] І за рік, сподіваюся,
[англійською] я зможу справді
добре говорити українською,
[англійською] але направду сьогодні
мені складно навіть англійською.